after casually destroying San Francisco
Godzilla is finally back after taking a
much-need vacation in Northern Africa in
this latest episode we'll be taking a
look at Godzilla's return where he might
be headed Lee and koo's relationship and
what present day Lee might be cooking up
before we get into it make sure to like
And subscribe if you want more Godzilla
videos as we travel back to 1955 it's
been one year since Godzilla was blown
away in the South Pacific and never seen
for again we are here at Monarch
Headquarters in Arlington Virginia
considerably less busy than present day
probably because the only three people
working there are Lee Bill and Koo
strange isotopic readings have been
found in Japan readings that are very
similar to what was found in the
Philippines near the USS Len these
readings come from hatara Japan's
southernmost inhabited Island this is
where we meet Dr Suzuki considered a bit
of a crackpot by the locals who has
built what he calls a Gam a radiation
simulator we know that Titans are
attracted to radiation so theoretically
turning this machine on will act as a
sort of Titan bait back in 2015 we'll
see that Hiroshi has taken Dr Suzuki's
idea and crafted his own simulator we
saw what looked like a photo of one of
these devices at his office in San
Francisco now that we know Hiroshi is
Alive and Well the question then becomes
why would he want to awaken Godzilla
especially after the disaster that was
jday when Verdugo and Tim visit
hiroshi's office we learned that Hiroshi
was fired for misuse of government
assets he'd been turning satellites to
point at Earth and found specific
locations that gave off highly irregular
readings these locations seem to point
to Titans such as the Frost vark found
in Alaska maybe Hiroshi is using this
simulator to awaken Godzilla so that he
can help save Humanity from these other
Titans other than North Africa Tim notes
that Hiroshi picked up two more gamma
ray Sur es one in Central Asia and the
other around Vietnam and Cambodia this
is likely where he's headed next but
there's also the question of why Hiroshi
went MIA from his kids and why he leaves
them in the Algerian desert I think
Hiroshi wanted to disappear for two main
reasons one his mission is all about
saving humanity and preventing what Lee
calls a gday times a thousand and
knowing how stubborn his kids are if
they found out what he was doing they'd
go after him putting themselves in
danger so in a way him going completely
off the grid is his way of protecting
them in North Africa him leaving could
be his attempt at leading Godzilla away
from them remember he has this huge
device on the back of his truck this is
why we don't see him attempt to link up
with them after Godzilla's emergence
we've been theorizing for over five
episodes now but we finally get
confirmation of Lee and Ko's
relationship at the summer ball of 1955
it looks like it's fully underway keep
in mind this is 3 years after they first
met met in the Philippines one year
after the atomic blast at bikini atal
and four years before KO falls into the
rubble of the Kazakhstan reactor in
Kazakhstan we learned that Koo and Bill
Randa are married you can see they both
have wedding rings which is something
they do not have in 1955 so something
happens between these four years to
shake up the Dynamics between these
three and if this episode is any
indication it looks like the reason Lee
and KO don't work out is Monarch itself
Lee thinks he's doing the right thing by
missing an important meeting with
General Pucket but instead flies out to
Japan to be with KO while this may seem
like a romantic gesture it ends up
jeopardizing the entire project when
they come back to see Pucket has put
somebody totally new in charge
additionally bill doesn't seem to know
about this little trist leading me to
believe he won't for the next four years
either since in 1959 it seems like the
three of them are all still good friends
there's a running line both Lee and KO
say this episode the things I do for
Monarch which I think is a play on the
things I do for love one of the big
reveals this episode is Michelle Duval's
turn from Monarch helping Lee Escape
captivity in Alaska this decision was
based on what happened to her sister
Sandra in janira the nuclear facility
attacked in 2014's Godzilla it's never
stated whether or not this is Sandra
Brody the nuclear physicist who died in
the attack and was married to Brian
cranston's Joe Brody coincidentally or
not she is portrayed by a french actor R
Juliet BOS Duval doesn't want what
happened to her sister to happen to
others so she sees Lee as the only guy
with a plan to make it stop hence
helping him escape two characters who
haven't been as forthcoming are Lee Shaw
and May Lee knows way more than he's
putting on and uses this to keep canaro
and Kate on a leash but if you come with
me you'll know everything I promise you
it's also revealed that Lee wants to
protect Godzilla something may calls him
crazy for this is likely why Lee split
ways with Monarch he sees Godzilla as a
protector while Monarch sees Godzilla as
a monster that needs to be destroyed
with Monarch being taken over by the
General's men at the end of the episode
this could be the start of Lee's
Divergence from Monarch as a whole may
also comes clean about selling out Ken
and Kate she was the one to inform Duval
where they were but we also get a bit
more information about her past she
states that a few years ago she pissed
off some people and ran away to Japan
this might have something to do with a
large sum of money she amassed money
which she says she hasn't touched with a
gang stranded with no passports or place
to go they'll probably have to dip into
this cash ma said she didn't touch this
money because it could alert the people
she stole it from so you better believe
if they take any of this money someone
will be on their tracks now we get into
the trailer sleuthing part of this video
where we take a look at the season's
trailers to see if we can glean any
information on what's to come I won't
cover every shot just the ones I think
are important check out this shot of a
man in woman's hands could this be Lee
and KO a particular note are what appear
to be bandages on the left hand so I'll
be keeping an eye out for anyone who has
an entry there in upcoming episodes this
is the shot that intrigues me the most
Lee on some sort of mission we'll see
him and others get into this giant ball
remember that Verdugo said Lee was
involved in a mission gone wrong my
guess is that this was a mission to
prove that the hollow Earth exists a
world within our world seen in Godzilla
versus Kong this mission may also
explain why Lee look so good for being
in his '90s I don't know if they could
make this work but imagine if KO was
still alive the last time we saw her she
fell into this giant crevice and if time
were to somehow work differently in the
hollow Earth it's possible she could
look the exact same even in 2015
remember that Dr Suzuki's findings
hinted that everything they know about
physics could be wrong if the data is
accurate inde then it means physics are
a similar large sphere can be seen in
2015 behind are characters here so
expect us learning more about what went
wrong in this mission in episodes to
come this is a really interesting shot
of Lee in front of a computer that says
Prime I wonder if he's setting off some
sort of bomb or the gamma simulator
judging by the fan in the background
he's talking to Kate and she looks a
little concerned now if I were writing
this show I think the coolest twist
would be if Lee has some sort of secret
plan to get KO back even if it means
going against the greater good we've
already seen him make this Choice when
he opted not to go and secure that
Monarch funding and rather travel to
Japan to be with her there's this shot
of Lee and two other unknown characters
that what appears to be a monarch
facility judging by the Monarch logo
barely visible on the computer screen
and it looks like Tim survived his
encounter with Godzilla after a blade
from the chopper he was in crashed into
it at some point he'll be taking Kate
canaro and may to the Monarch
headquarters in Virginia but just how
all of these weave together in the next
four episodes remains to be seen and I
hope you'll stick with me as the show
nears its climax now I want to hear from
you what are your thoughts and theories
on what will happen next thanks for
watching please be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
Daddy loves you very
much